on connaît les smartphones qui se plient
est-ce que vous connaissez les
ordinateurs qui se plaisent ça c'est une
technologie que nous montre Samsung
puisqu'ils peuvent plier des écrans
petits ils peuvent payer des très grands
écrans et on se parle ici du flex note
c'est l'idée d'apporter de la modularité
à un ordinateur on l'a vu notamment chez
Asus avec son Zenbook folle ou zenfold
book bref peu importe ici Samsung
display nous montre cette technologie
qui vient se plier d'un côté lol sur ça
intéressant une fois de plus mais
surtout vous est-ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser d'avoir un ordinateur qui se
plie est-ce que vous voyez vraiment de
l'intérêt à cette modularité alors on se
parle bien évidemment d'ordinateur mais
ça peut être aussi des tablettes parce
qu'une tablette c'est quand même
relativement grande déjà encombrement
mais imaginez vous pourriez l'ouvrir
davantage ça vous ferait une énorme
tablette pourquoi pas un 17 pouces dans
la poche avec un petit format j'en sais
rien de 11 pouces imaginons ça pourrait
être intéressant moi je trouve ça une
fois de plus assez cool alors le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que la techno
sont quand même très épaisses il faut
réussir à venir diminuer l'encombrement
mais c'est peut-être un des possibles
pour l'avenir des ordinateurs déjà des
smartphones et peut-être des PC
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que ça pourrait vous
tenter oui non marquez moi ça dans les
commentaires